hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast CTS stem Pro HSC
expansion medium for cell and gene
therapies presented by Abigail Harris
Becker scientists Thermo Fisher
Scientific I'm Christie Joel of lab rats
and I will be your moderator for today's
event this presentation is brought to
you by laborat and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher com
I would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
in the ask a question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I would now like to introduce today's
speaker abigail harris becker scientist
Thermo Fisher Scientific Abigail
completed her master's degree in
biomedical sciences at Penn State
College of Medicine in Hershey
Pennsylvania where her graduate research
focused on the role of genetic and
epigenetic alterations of acute myeloid
leukemia abigail joined Thermo Fisher
Scientific in the cell biology business
based in Frederick Maryland in 2016 as a
rnd scientist abigail is part of a team
focused on research and development of
cell therapy grade products that support
translational and clinical research
workflow for a complete biography on
abigail harris becker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Abigale you may now begin your
presentation
you
Thank You Christy hello I'm Abigail
Harris Becker and I work at Thermo
Fisher Scientific in the R&D department
that focuses on cell and gene therapies
therapy stick life at the enablement
stage but there is a need to build in
sustainability to develop these
therapies into commercial products that
can meet patient demand thermo Fisher
has the global footprint and a history
of providing high quality technologies
and regulatory support that clinicians
need as they move to sustainable
manufacturing of these new therapies
our CTF products are developed to help
ease the transition from the bench to
the clinic in addition to GMP
manufacturing and quality systems our
CTS products provide traceability and
regulatory support currently our
products are already in fda approved
therapies and more than 100 clinical
trials
one of our most recent CTS products
focuses on Hamada poetic stem cells or
HSCs HSCs are self renewing multipotent
progenitor cells that are found in the
bone marrow and peripheral blood and are
defined by cd34 surface marker
expression HSCs
are of particular interest as potential
treatments for blood disorders
immunological diseases and cancer HSCs
can be genetically modified for example
by transfection or transduction as shown
here on the right and then transplanted
into the patient to provide long-term
protection from disease the modified
HSCs must successfully and graft into
the patient's bone marrow in order for
HSCs to engraft and repopulate the bone
marrow they must retain their full
functionality proliferation and
differentiation capacity one of the
major limitations to utilizing HSCs and
cell therapy is the limits on cell
numbers that can be harvested from a
single bone marrow or cord blood donor
expanding HSCs ex vivo would increase
the number of patients that could be
treated with a single harvest from
either bone marrow or cord blood however
ex vivo expansion of harvested HSCs
results in rapid differentiation and
progressive loss of cd34 expression
current media systems support the cd34
positive progenitors that provide
short-term bone marrow reconstitution
long-term engraftment requires the true
hamada politic stem cells which are
thought to be cd34 positive CD 90
positive in the CD 45 are a negative
subset
however this subpopulation of HSCs is
currently not effectively expanded in
commercially available media systems
to address this challenge we use an
iterative design of experiments approach
to develop cts dem pro HSC expansion
medium with the goal of maintaining and
expanding that rare cd34 positive CD 90
positive CD 45 are a negative population
the data on this slide focuses on CD 34
positive cells from mobilized peripheral
blood from three donors the cells were
expanded in CGS stem Pro HSC expansion
medium supplemented with stem cell
factor split three ligand thrombopoietin
interleukin three and interleukin 6
after seven days we evaluated the total
nucleated cells or TNC and cell
viability and we determined the
phenotype by flow cytometry using the
attune NXT flow cytometry
we show that stem Pro HSC expansion
medium provides about a 100 fold
expansion and all three donors shown
here and that more than 60% of the
expanded cells are cd34 positive note
that while the competitor media expands
both the total nucleated cells and cd34
positive cells only stem Pro HSC medium
expands both the short-term cd34
positive progenitors and it provides far
superior expansion of the long term cd34
positive CD 90 positive cd45 are a
negative cell population
transplantation of ex-vivo cultured cd34
positive cells is the gold standard to
assess whether or not the expanded cells
maintain their functionality here cd34
positive cells from mobilized peripheral
blood were expanded for seven days in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium
supplemented with the same five growth
factors the expanded cells were then
transplanted into immunodeficient energy
mice after six months we monitored human
cd45 positive cell populations in both
the bone marrow and spleen obviously you
wouldn't expect any human cells in mice
so the presence of any human cd45
positive cells or Kaymer ISM indicates
that these human cells have persisted at
six months post transplantation this is
indicative that the cells did
successfully engraft into the bone
marrow when these cells that were
cultured in stem Pro HSC expansion
medium were transplanted into the NRG
mice we see that humans cd45 positive
cells are tenfold higher in bone marrow
and twofold higher and spleen compared
to the non expanded cells in addition
the cells exhibited multi lineage and
graffman including cd34 positive HSCs CD
33 positive myeloid cells and CD
positive CD 19 positive b-cells
in addition to maintaining the cd34
positive stem cell population stem Pro
HSC expansion medium supports
megakaryocytes and erythrocyte
progenitor cells
megakaryocytes are the progenitors that
differentiate into platelets while
erythroid progenitors differentiate into
red blood cells here cd34 positive cells
from mobilized peripheral blood were
expanded for seven days in stem Pro HSC
expansion medium supplemented with the
same five growth factors at the end of
the seven days we evaluated total
nucleated cells and cell viability in
addition we looked at the immuno
phenotype
and determine the percent expression of
cd34 CD 41 and CD 71 using the attune
NXT flow cytometry here you see a more
than 2,000 fold increase of both the
cd34 positive CD forty one positive
megakaryocytes progenitor population as
well as the cd34 positive CD 71 positive
erythroid progenitor population
here we show cd34 positive cells
isolated from the three most common
tissue sources three mobilized
peripheral blood donors - cord blood
donors and - bone marrow donors the
cells were expanded in stem Pro HSC
expansion medium shown in blue or one of
two supplier media again while all three
media expand the total number of cells
and maintain cd34 positive expression as
shown in the top and middle charts stem
Pro HSC expansion medium expands both
the cd34 positive progenitor cells and
provides superior expansion of the long
term cd34 positive CD 90 positive cd45
are a negative population
I'll move on to methods for genetically
modifying HSCs for cell therapies here
mobilised peripheral blood cd34 positive
cells were thawed and pre stimulated in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium containing
the same five growth factors for 48
hours cells were then transduced for
another 48 hours with CTS LV max
generated GFP virus at the various mo
eye is indicated transduction efficiency
was evaluated by flow cytometry at 48 72
and 120 hours post transduction
on the left the top row of dot plots
shows the percent of cells that are
double positive for GFP and cd34 at the
mo I indicated the bottom row of dot
plot shows the cells that are triple
positive for GFP cd34
and CD 90 moving to the right the middle
two charts show the percentage of cells
that express both GFP and cd34 as well
as the mean fluorescence intensity of
the GFP expression in addition all time
points and all mo eyes showed high
viability
data shows that cd34 positive cells
cultured in CTS temporal HSC expansion
medium can be transduced with Lenti
viral vectors with a 5-2 38%
transduction efficiency when using the
cts lv max system
crisper cast 9 gene editing allows
genetic material to be added removed or
altered at particular locations in the
genome here mobilize peripheral blood
cd34 positive cells were cultured in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium prior to
neon electroporation for the transection
of true cut cast 9 protein guide RNA and
GFP donor DNA
cd34 positive cells cultured in stem Pro
HSC medium showed approximately 20%
transfection efficiency as a point of
reference t-cell transfection efficiency
with this system is approximately 10%
here we're showing the percentage of gfp
positive cells
cd34 positive cells and CD 90 positive
cells as determined using the attune and
xt flow cytometry the Center chart shows
that cd34 positive CD 90 positive cells
are present in the gfp positive
population demonstrating that these
long-term HSCs are permissible to gene
editing using this system
the far-right panel shows the in vitro
colony-forming assay of gfp positive
cells here we're showing that
this resulted in granulocyte and
macrophage colony is designated as white
colonies here as well as erythroid or
red colonies this indicates that the
functional capacity of the cells has
been maintained following
electroporation
in summary CTS stem Pro HSC expansion
medium was developed for cell therapy
applications with regulatory compliance
in mind it is a serum free Zeno free
cGMP manufactured media system that is
supported by a drug master file and
regulatory support file to assist our
customers in global regulatory filings
and approvals the media system expands
cd34 positive cells from the most
commonly used tissue sources and
enriches for the rare cd34 positive CD
90 positive CD 45 re- subpopulation it
maintains HSC functionality and
differentiation capacity and enables the
expansion of cd34 positive cd4 T one
positive megakaryocytes progenitor z'
and cd34 positive CD 71 positive
erythroid progenitors in addition it
facilitates engraftment in an animal
transplant model and is compatible with
gene editing and transduction workflows
additional data and information can be
found at thermo Fisher comm forward
slash stem Pro HSC thank you for your
attention and now I'd like to open it up
for questions
you
Thank You Abigail for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar also joining
us for our live Q&A we have sandy
kulakowski senior regulatory affairs
manager and Tracy Cross that senior
product manager cell and gene therapy
okay now if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is what type of GMP
are CTF cell culture medium manufactured
according to all right this is sandy our
CTS products are manufactured at sites
that are 13 485 certified compliant with
the US FDA quality system regulation 21
CFR part e 20 and registered with the
FDA our CTS products themselves are
generally not medical devices but the
manufacturing sites do manufacture
medical devices and the quality systems
are aligned to medical device
manufacturing standards
Thank You sandy our next question why is
the cd34 positive CD 90 positive
phenotype significance
hi this is Abigail in part why that
phenotype is significant stems from a
2017 publication out of the Fred hutch
Institute and that research team showed
that this cd34 positive CD 90 positive
cd45 are a negative population was
highly enriched for stem cells and that
this sub population was in particular
was responsible for multi lineage
engraftment in a non-human primate
transplantation model and if anyone's
interested in that publication it's in
science of translational medicine again
from 2017
Thank You Abigail all right next
question how do i request a DM ethyl
regulatory support file for this product
a thermo Fisher website you can request
a letter of authorization and you will
need to complete an online form
outlining the products you are using a
clinical application reference number
and title agency division in your
company contact details and we will
process your request and contact you if
we have any further information most
requests are completed within a week's
time
thank you do I have to use the growth
factors that you recommend
so we evaluated the five growth factors
that we recommend using a design of
experiments evaluation and we found that
these five growth factors do produce the
best expansion and maintenance of the
cd34 positive CD 90 positive phenotype
at so at the moment that is what we
recommend for top performance and if
someone wants to use different growth
factors they'll have to conduct that
evaluation to see how it performs in
their hands
our next question in what system where
the cells expanded bioreactor flasks
we used blast and multi-well plates at
the moment that's the data that we have
no bioreactors yet
thank you now the data showed seven days
of HSC culture will I get more shells if
I culture for longer than seven days we
found that seven days of expansion was
optimal in terms of the expansion of the
HSCs
as well as the maintenance of Gd 34
expression if you want a culture for
less than seven days obviously you'll
have fewer cells at after four days and
culture we saw about a twenty five fold
increase in cd34 positive cells and they
maintained greater than 95% of cd34
expression and if you want a culture for
longer than seven days you'll obviously
get more cells but you are do start to
lose the cd34 expression so we do
recommend a seven-day culture and for
convenience you don't have to change the
media over that course of that seven
days
thank you now we have some great
questions coming in I want to just
remind our audience that those questions
we do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration okay our next
question do you have any thought on
oxygen concentration fourth-best
HSC expansion
so we use standard culture conditions
here so incubator at 36 to 38 degrees
and a four to six percent co2 and all of
these specifications are included in the
product manual
q do we have any suggestions regarding
most efficient method of cell culturing
suspension adherent R&D phase bioreactor
so all of the cells that we showed data
for so the HFCS from mobilized
peripheral blood cord blood and bone
marrow that was all suspension culture
in terms of bioreactor work we have not
completed that yet
we are looking at closed systems
including like let's say a finesse you
know bag and the to room oh quantum but
we have not generated that data at this
time
the next question what is the format of
the media
so the media comes as a kit it's a basal
media that you store at 4 degrees and a
50 X up limit that is stored at minus 20
it doesn't contain any growth factors or
cytokines so you do need to supplement
with growth factors or cytokines it
doesn't require any other additions you
know serum or anything like that so it
does come as a media kit and at this
time we're only selling the two
components together
cute for next question
you're do-e for the growth factors did
you also evaluate different
concentrations for each factor and can
you share what concentration you used
yes
so we did a a full iterative goe
looking at not only the five growth
factors to ensure that each one was
contributing but we also looked at
different concentrations so the
concentrations that we recommend also
came out of that goe the final
concentrations that we recommend are
included in the product manual just
quickly the stem cell factor flip three
Ligon and gpo are all at 100 nanograms
per mil interleukin three is at fifty
nanograms per ml and interleukin 6 is at
twenty so you don't have to write all of
that down this is all available on the
website and in the user manual on it's
spelled out and we also provide catalog
numbers for those growth factors
you
thank you just now thank you again
Abigail Tracy and Sandy do you have any
final comments for our audience
yes I'd like to thank everyone for
attending today and if you'd like any
additional information please visit
thermo Fisher comm slash stem Pro HSE
the link you see on your screen is
clickable and if you go to that site we
have additional applications data the
product manual and fa Q's
and thank you very much for your time
and attention
thank you now people rego I'd like to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
again those questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank
abigail harris becker tracy cross vet
and sandy kulakowski for their time
today and we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand and Mavericks will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be redirected to the registration
page of our upcoming webinar featuring
Carty generation for identity purity
potency and sterility assays testing
presented by dr. Tiye hexam sign up now
for more details that's all for now and
we hope to see you again soon have a
great day